the next four years won't be great for
some of the most vulnerable members of
society but if you want inspiration take
a close look at Standing Rock the
protesters there didn't pack up and
leave when the Army Corps of Engineers
said work on the controversial section
of the pipeline would stop despite the
freezing cold they're staying because
they know that in just a few weeks we'll
have a president who's financially
invested in the project last year Donald
Trump had up to a million dollars
invested in energy transfer Partners
that's the company building the pipeline
even though his spokeswoman says he sold
his shares last month he still has up to
250 thousand dollars in phillips 66
which owns a quarter of the pipeline now
during his campaign Trump also picked up
a one-hundred-thousand-dollar donation
from Kelsey Warren that's the CEO of
energy transfer partners for as closest
trump is to the energy industry he's
just as far from respecting or
understanding the concerns of Native
Americans obviously it's not just Native
Americans that are at risk here this is
precisely why we should all be focused
on Standing Rock the protests United
hundreds of tribes and thousands of
people against a massive corporation
backed by militarized police who didn't
hold back when it came to using water
cannons rubber bullets and stun grenades
month after month it's protesters and
independent journalists were arrested
the story was missing from the
mainstream but as social media coverage
swelled solidarity protest group and so
did the coverage especially of the
veterans who were standing alongside the
protesters now I'm keeping this word
solidarity up here because it's the key
to the success of every struggle for
rights and equality especially when we
have a president who talks about
protesters like this like the punch him
in the face the upcoming struggle is an
opportunity to write some of the
countless wrongs committed against
Native Americans today the poverty rate
of single race Native Americans is
twenty eight point three percent that's
the highest of any individual race group
in the con
in North Dakota the unemployment rate is
just over three percent but for the
Standing Rock tribe it's an incredible
seventy-nine percent worse Native
Americans are one of the group's most
likely to be killed by police it's
either Native Americans or
african-americans depending on the year
and they're also the group most likely
to have their deaths at the hands of
police go unrecorded but let's not
forget history just because it haunts us
just because the genocide that wiped out
Native Americans is at odds with
so-called American exceptionalism let's
read up on the broken treaties the
federal government used to steal their
land it's completely understandable to
be scared about the future of America
and to worry about so many hard fought
for rights disappearing but the people
at Standing Rock know that this is only
the start in another chapter of a very
long fight